chaos continues in kenosha wisconsin and
spreads to minneapolis as a false rumor
of another police shooting goes viral
the nba closes down to protest supposed
systemic american racism
and the rnc defense cops and the flag on
its third night i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet visit expressvpn.com
well before we begin i'd be remiss if i
did not mention it's a little volatile
out there you may have noticed this i
mean we have a double-barreled hurricane
that is now moving
toward america's coast and it's already
hitting we have massive riots in the
streets
of the united states we have a big
election coming up a lot of uncertainty
out there i've been telling you to
invest at least a little bit in precious
metals since 2016.
don't you wish you'd listen to me that
was way back when gold was 1300 bucks an
ounce
and just look now gold is at a new
all-time high why well gold and silver
thrive on uncertainty when you're
talking about a coveted pandemic with
massive unemployment
and a monumental election around the
corner and the chinese firing missiles
into the south china sea
well there's a lot of uncertainty out
there so you might want to take some of
your money and put it
in precious metals if you haven't
reached out to my friends at birch gold
to diversify part of your ira or 401k
into a precious metals ira
or just get some physical gold or silver
from them go ahead and do it today
text ben 247 4747 get a free information
kit on protecting your savings with gold
listen
i have some precious metals you should
too i trust the folks over at birch gold
they've got an a plus rating with the
better business bureau
and countless five-star reviews talk to
them have them help you safeguard your
investments they're extremely
knowledgeable they want to help you
protect your savings ask all your
questions get all your answers
and then think about investing at least
a little bit in precious metals by
texting ben to 47 47 47
when you open an ira in precious metals
before august 30th you'll be the first
to get a signed copy of my new book how
to destroy america
in three easy steps for free it's pretty
relevant right now again text ben 247 47
47 hurry up get the special offer text
ben 247
47 47 okay we're gonna get to everything
that is happening in domestic american
politics including the burning
of more major american cities as we
continue to back the narrative that
america is systemically racist and evil
and then watch as people burn down
large american cities in small american
cities kenosha's a town of about a
hundred thousand people
but here is your quick hurricane laura
update according to weather.com at this
hour hurricane laura has now moved
inland across louisiana with damaging
winds flooding rain and tornadoes after
category four
landfall this is wind gusts of up to 100
to 135
miles per hour being recorded in
southwestern louisiana
according to weather.com hurricane laura
made landfall early thursday morning is
now tracking northward
across western louisiana with threats of
destructive winds flooding rainfall
storm surges and tornadoes laura made
landfall near cameron louisiana at 1am
central time as a strong category 4 with
150 mile per hour winds
this is the first category 4 landfalling
hurricane on record
according to the noaa laura is now
tracking through western louisiana as a
category 2 hurricane
this morning which is certainly better
than a category 4. the hurricane's winds
will slowly weaken as it moves further
inland toward
arkansas today the winds have not got
power to more than 600 000 homes and
businesses
in southeast texas and louisiana there's
extensive wind damage
in lake charles louisiana including
numerous shattered windows in downtown
skyscrapers a communication tower
collapsed
power pulse toppled and roofs shredded
some of the footage is pretty
astonishing
trees and power lines were reported down
all over the city in shreveport
according
to local law enforcement multiple down
lines and power lines
also blocked roads through caldwell
parish louisiana there have also been
reports of wind damage from lafayette
starks and vincent louisiana and natchez
mississippi
hurricane warnings have been dropped at
the immediate coast they continue for
inland parishes of louisiana listen to
your local authorities if you are in the
path of this thing and they're telling
you to get out of the way
then get out of the way because you
don't want to be in the way of this one
okay meanwhile the country continues to
burn and it continues to burn because
there is a narrative and the narrative
must be pervaded at all costs
it is a narrative push by the media it's
an error to push by the democratic party
it is a narrative that america is
systemically racist and that every
incident caught on film of a white
police officer in an altercation with a
black citizen
stems from america's terrible history of
racism these are the 16 19 riots they
continue
this is all rooted in a certain ideology
it's an ideology i talk about is
disintegrationism in my book how to
destroy america in three easy steps
which is now more relevant than ever
unfortunately
the philosophy of disintegrationism says
that we don't actually share any values
all we are are a series of competing
interests a series of competing tribal
interests who are unified because we are
basically locked in this prison together
and therefore whoever has the power is
the person who makes the rules
and the only way to rest the power is to
use whatever means are at your disposal
and we are seeing this take place on the
streets of kenosha wisconsin we're
seeing this take place
in the streets of minneapolis we're
seeing this take place in the halls of
power politically
and in corporate america and we're
seeing the media egg it all on because
the media liked the narrative the media
believed the narrative that america is
systemically racist and systemically
evil and so they are not going to be
concerned with any of the facts of any
given situation
not one they're not going to care that
it now turns out
that jacob blake had a knife they're not
going to care about that
it now turns out that they found on the
floorboards of the car where he was
reaching in when he was shot jacob blake
this is the 29 year old black man who
was shot by the police in kenosha
wisconsin
after the police were called because of
a domestic disturbance
that is a man who had an open warrant
for domestic violence and sexual assault
he drove to some house apparently the
person in the house called the police
because he was trying to grab her keys
he was in a place he should not have
been this is according to the police
scanner phone call
they pulled up his police record they
saw he had an open warrant he had
resisted arrest before
they arrived he resisted arrest again
and they apparently tried to tase him it
didn't work
he got up he walked around to the other
side of the car while they shouted at
him to stop
and they had their guns drawn he reached
down inside the car
they don't know if he's got a gun there
they don't know if he's got a knife
there it turns out there was a knife
apparently on the floorboards of the car
this is what you call a justified
shooting that is not prosecutable okay
there's no way this is prosecutable in a
court of law
at all zero chance this gets prosecuted
this is a there's an open arrest warrant
for a man with a history of violence
with police
domestic violence and sexual assault
they actively attempt to arrest him
peacefully he resists arrest throws them
off disobeys orders goes to the front of
his car
reaches inside and then they found a
knife on the floorboards
hey you wonder why he was shot that's
why he was shot it's amazing we
constantly hear these stories
from black parents particularly in the
media talking about how they have to
give the talk to their kids you know
obey the police because you never know
what the police are going to do first of
all
my understanding is that every single
person who drives like when you get your
driver's license
you have this particular talk like in
driver's training they literally tell
you put your hands to ten and two obey
the orders of the police
don't reach for the glove box right i
have this talk with my parents and it's
not race-based it's a
don't upset the police situation because
you don't want the police to shoot you
okay you're not supposed to reach for
the glove box no matter what your race
is
unless you are telling the police what
exactly is in the glove box you're
supposed to be very careful about how
you interact with police in all
circumstances
but if you're going to name a situation
in which the talk didn't work you cannot
name jacob blake as such a situation
the man disobeyed every single order he
actively resisted arrest
he reached into his car into a place the
cops apparently could not see
and there was a knife in the car so i
i'm really wanting to know here
what exactly you expect the cops to do i
saw people suggesting oh well the cops
should have tased him they tried to
apparently
okay so so this is a textbook example of
a non-prosecutable
shooting by a police officer according
to the new reports from the milwaukee
journal sentinel the wisconsin
department of justice wednesday evening
named the officer who shot jacob lake
and provided additional information
about the shooting
blake had a knife on the driver's side
floorboard on the driver's side of
floorboard
okay that would be like where he was
reaching guys you can see it in the tape
he's reaching to the driver's side
floorboard after
resisting arrest after resisting arrest
what do you think the cops are going to
do in that situation you're going to sit
around and wait for him to wheel on them
with a knife
okay this is my favorite part here is
the headline okay here is the headline
originally from the wisconsin from the
wisconsin journal sentinel the milwaukee
journal sentinel this was the original
headline you ready
listen to this jacob blake had knife in
car but was otherwise unarmed
wisconsin's doj says as it releases name
of kenosha officer who shot him
in the back well he had a knife in the
car but otherwise he was unarmed
well you know that that that night at
the theater for abraham lincoln
it was i mean aside from the aside from
the shooting it was otherwise a fairly
decent night
what in the world does that mean aside
that scene in terminator 2 where arnold
schwarzenegger is standing at the window
holding a minigun aside from the minigun
he was otherwise unarmed it seems
like what in the what in what does that
headline even mean
the headline is so dedicated to the
narrative that jacob lake was wrongfully
shot that they are going to actively
downplay
one of the key factors in him being shot
namely disobeying the police and
apparently going for a weapon on the
driver's side floorboard of the car so
one of two things is true
okay so we don't actually know whether
he had the knife before that either he
was already walking with the knife and
reaching into the car in which case
still a good shoot or he was reaching
into the car for the knife in which case
still a good shoot and by the way even
if there had not been a knife there when
you disobey the cops and you do the
specific thing they tell you not to do
in the talk
then why are we acting as though this is
unjustified seriously legally
unjustified
okay but again the narrative matters
more than anything that is all that
matters
so naturally the democratic governor of
wisconsin completely failed in his duty
to protect the city of kenosha
over the past 72 hours the city of
kenosha burned again
last night and over the past 72 hours we
saw this horrible situation
where a 17 year old man and you're a man
by law you can be tried as a man by law
a 17 year old man shot three people in
kenosha wisconsin
and the media jumped on this story not
just because there was shooting it was
really not just because they were
shooting because there have been
shootings
at other black lives matter protests and
riots and lootings
in fact last count i think over 30
people have been shot in these various
riots and lootings
and but this one obviously drew national
attention because in this particular
case it was a white 17 year old who shot
apparently three other white people by
the way i mean that's sort of
worthwhile mentioning okay so the the
three people he shot were white
okay so the media jumped on this
particular incident specifically
because these were quote unquote armed
militia members who had arrived in
kenosha wisconsin
in order to defend private property and
the person who did the shooting is a guy
named kyle rittenhouse
he's 17 years old and he traveled from
illinois in order to defend private
property
okay so many things can be true here at
once one
you probably if you're not an agent for
a business in the state of wisconsin
you cannot just go and defend somebody
else's property that's not the way it
works the way
like if you're hired as a security guard
you can defend the property and you have
all the rights of the owner
with regard to the property if you're
not an agent of the owner then you don't
have the same rights to protect the
owner's property
two you're allowed to protect your own
life if somebody threatens your life
if somebody threatens to do you bodily
harm of course the rights of
self-defense still apply
three a 17 year old should not be out
there this is not the place for an
untrained 17 year old is in the middle
of a riot
and that is not a place that a 17 year
old should be okay
four just because all of those things
happen to be true
does not mean that this guy is guilty of
first-degree murder we're gonna go
through the tape we're gonna go through
the timeline
and then we we do have to ask the
question here why is this happening and
the answer is why this is happening is
because governor tony evers who's a
horrible governor decided he was not
going to call in the national guard
sufficient to quash
the rioting and the looting and the
violence because in the view of so many
democratic mayors and governors of
cities
they've decided that it's worthwhile to
give people space to let things burn
in the famous words of the former
baltimore mayor during the baltimore
riots in 2015
2014 2015. remember the mayor of
baltimore said we needed to give them
space to burn
okay this has been the perspective for
many democrats in the city of los
angeles where i live eric garcetti shut
down the entire city for a week running
at 7 pm to give people space to loot and
burn
if you don't want this to happen there's
a very easy way to stop it and that is
you call in the national guard and you
stop it dead
you stop it cold when that doesn't
happen you know what happens
people start to defend other people's
property people start to move in and
they start to
confront people who are committing
active violence and looting in fact
you know the single best example of how
violence in communities rises when you
remove law enforcement
that's what's been happening in these
high crime areas a lot of people ask why
is there this great differential in
murder rates and between blacks and
blacks and between whites and whites for
example the murder rate in the black
community's about nine times higher
somewhere between seven and nine times
higher
than in the white community has been for
generations at this point why is that
well the original reason thomas solo
points out
is because white communities basically
said to black communities you're on your
own we're not going to give you police
resources
and thus what you ended up with is what
you have everywhere where there is no
centralized
authority that ensures law and order and
support for property rights
what you end up with is people gathering
to defend themselves and defend their
properties and property of their friends
against other human beings
where the mob rules chaos reigns as i
pointed out yesterday
well the mob ruled in wisconsin and
chaos reigned in wisconsin and so it is
a
a just it is a perfectly predictable
it is a perfectly predictable response
that you're going to get people who
in in vigilante fashion decide that
they're going to go out and protect
the private property of other people now
should they be doing that without the
training no should a 17 year old be out
there no
that does not mean that the person who
committed the shooting was a quote
unquote white supremacist okay that was
the rumor that started floating around
yesterday there's not one
iota of evidence that kyle written house
is a white supremacist at this point not
one
not an iota not a shred doesn't matter
senator chris murphy that disgusting
human being
in order to generate more of a narrative
senator chris murphy from connecticut he
tweeted out
i wonder why a deranged white
nationalist trump supporter would show
up at a protest with a rifle and start
shooting people
that is 100 not what happened that is
100 not what happened it doesn't matter
the narrative has to be promulgated the
lie has to be promulgated
that is not what happened doesn't mean
the 17 year old should have been out
there
but this kid this person i'm gonna call
him a man he's 17 years old
he is not going to this young man he is
not going to be prosecuted for first
degree murder because it's an
unsustainable charge
nor was he out there willy-nilly
shooting people that is not what
happened and if you believe the media
telling you this it's because they're
lying to you and they think you are
stupid and you don't have eyes in your
head
or a prefrontal cortex that is
operational we're gonna get to the
specific facts of the case i know we're
not supposed to talk specific facts of
cases anymore
we're just supposed to be bullied into
believing who is the villain and who is
the hero
and who is the criminal and who is the
non-criminal in these particular
situations
we're supposed to just believe that on
the basis of no evidence whatsoever
that the officers in the briana taylor
killing need to be rounded up and they
need to be prosecuted despite the fact
that there is no criminal
law basis for their prosecution we're
supposed to believe that the officers in
the jacob blake
shooting need to be rounded up and
prosecuted and put in jail for life
despite the fact that there is no
sustainable prosecutorial case against
them
hell we're supposed to believe that the
officer in the michael brown shooting is
guilty even though there were two
separate
state prosecutors and an obama doj
investigation that found that the
shooting was justified
you're just supposed to believe the
narrative and if you look at the facts
this apparently makes you racially
insensitive
because then the overall narrative must
be supported and if the facts are not
sufficient to sustain the narrative
you just ignore the facts on the ground
so because
the media wish to ignore the writing and
the looting because the media are
rooting in many ways for the rioting and
the looting
many in the media are are interested in
sustaining the rationale behind the
writing and looting
because of as we're gonna see this okay
because of all of that
you end up with more rioting you know
with more looting you know with more
violence and you end up with a false
narrative
that the violence began in kenosha
wisconsin when the
armed militia arrived which is the same
thing basically as saying that when the
federal troops arrived in portland the
violence began on a timeline basis to
lie it's always been a lie the violence
preceded the federal troops arriving in
portland
it is now post-dating the federal troops
leaving in portland
the federal forces leaving in portland
and guess what if the armed militia goes
away tomorrow kenosha the rioting and
the looting will continue
because the armed militia showed up
these armed guys showing up to protect
private property allegedly
they showed up after the rioting and
looting you think they're just hanging
out in kenosha
and then black lives matter showed up
that's not how this happened but the
narrative has to be maintained at all
costs
the real bad guys in this situation are
anybody who shows up to protect
private property even even if they
shouldn't be there
the writers and looters are not it can't
be that there are two sets of people who
did something wrong it's got to be
there's one set of people who did
something wrong and one group
of absolute heroes and we're going to
twist the narrative in order to get
there
we'll get to how the media twisted this
narrative because it really is
incredible you have to ignore
every fact on the ground in order to get
to this narrative and we'll get there
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact that you may have noticed
now's a terrible time to go to an auto
parts store
like a really really bad time now the
truth is it's never a great time to go
to an auto parts store you're gonna get
overcharged for the part
if you are a layman you're gonna get
charged more than an expert you may not
know enough about your car to get the
right part they may give you a generic
part that's not as good they may have to
order the part and then up charge you
because they have to order it in
why don't just use the interwebs the way
you do for everything else you buy check
out rockauto.com
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear like airlines do
why spend up to twice as much for the
same part like say you happen to need a
delphi fg 1456 fuel pump assembly for a
2005-2010 honda autosai
odyssey it'll cost you like 354 bucks at
a big chain store it'll cost you 217
at rockauto rockauto.com is a family
business serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years head on over to
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
spend up to twice as much
for the same parts go check out
rockauto.com right now amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need rockauto.com head on
over
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
right shapiro in there how did you hear
about xbox so they know that we sent you
again right shapiro in there how did you
hear about his box at rockauto.com so
they know
that we sent you okay so the media are
absolutely twisting
the story of what happened with with
kyle rittenhouse again
doesn't mean the 17 year old should be
crossing state lines with a gun i
believe there's a gun charged here
he'll probably get convicted of the gun
charge this is not a first degree murder
case
there's no legal standard by which you
can claim based on the available footage
beyond a reasonable doubt there's a
first degree murder case here is how the
media covered it however ap
a white 17 year old police admirer was
arrested wednesday after two people were
shot to death during a third straight
night of protest in kenosha
over the police shooting of a black man
jacob blake kyle written house of
antioch illinois about 15 miles from
kenosha was taken into custody in
illinois on suspicion of first degree
intentional homicide in the attack
tuesday that was largely captured on
cell phone video
the shooting left a third person wounded
i just killed somebody the gunman
carrying a semi-automatic rifle could be
heard
saying at one point okay it takes until
paragraph 18
paragraph 18 of this story to
explain what exactly happened here
apparently what actually happened here
is that he was attacked twice
okay so i i we and we have all this on
tape there's plenty of cell phone videos
so let's go through the cell phone video
by the way
this is not my account of what happened
that night this is now the time the
account of the new york times
a person named christian trebert is the
visual investigations guy
at the new york times and he used to
work for the
he used to work for the um
i believe the milwaukee journal sentinel
um but in any case
he actually traced the movements of this
person
so the night began for kyle rittenhouse
explaining to
various members of conservative media
who are on the ground they're doing the
actual coverage
why he was there so here's the 17 year
old guy explaining that not only is he
there to protect private property he's
also trained emt so he's there to
provide medical attention to people
by the way in the early hours of this
particular riot he provided medical
attention to the writers and the looters
okay that is not a white supremacist out
to shoot rioters and looters here was
kyle rittenhouse explaining
we're protecting from the citizens and i
just got pepper sprayed by a
person in the crowd so you had
non-lethal but
you
so you guys are full and ready to defend
the property yes we are okay
now if i can ask can you guys step back
medical ems right here i am an emp
okay so literally at the end of the tape
he says i'm an emt i'm happy to help
right those are riders and lovers
those are the protesters right i'm happy
to help
okay at one point written house walks up
to a police vehicle with his rifle swung
and he talks with the police officers
and one tosses a water bottle to them
this has been used as evidence that the
police officers
are in league with these guys okay these
guys are not violating the law at this
point if you're over the age of 18
you're allowed to publicly carry
in wisconsin for virtually any reason
okay so
it only starts to become a crime if you
wrongfully use the gun
okay so what happens according christian
tree bird is that ridden house
eventually leaves the
car dealership that he is defending and
he's barred by the police
from returning at that point because he
has crossed the line
and then there were six separate live
streams so there were two separate
shooting incidents one
about a minute and a half earlier than
the other
so in the first you can see rittenhouse
he's being chased into a parking lot
okay while he's being pursued this is
according to the new york times while he
is being pursued
an unknown gunman fires the first shot
into the air so he doesn't fire the
first shot somebody else is chasing him
and fires the first shot you can
actually see it in in another angle of
this particular tape but here is what
then what happens is he goes behind a
car there's a man who is who's throwing
things at him and chasing him
he hears some shouting and then he he
fires
right according to the new york times
while he is being pursued an unknown
gunman fires the first shot into the air
rittenhouse turns toward the sound of
the gunfire as another pursuer lunges
toward him he then fires four times with
his assault rifle and appears to shoot
the man in the head okay so this is all
disturbing footage so you've been warned
uh here is the
here's the tape you can see rittenhouse
being pursued
by this guy chasing him he throws
something it's not a molotov cocktail by
the way it's a it's a bag filled with
something
okay and then there's a slight delay and
then you see
the shots go off okay now at this point
at this point it's unclear why
rittenhouse was being chased why he was
in the area of this car dealership about
four blocks away from the one
that he was originally protecting okay
the the initial
shot were fired by three more shots in
the parking lot we don't know
who fired them rittenhouse then takes
out his phone and he makes a phone call
he calls 9-1-1
to both turn himself in because somebody
has been shot right you can see him
there
on the cell phone and he's calling he's
calling the cops to come
and then people start chasing him again
so people start chasing him again which
brings us to tape number two
now he's running away from a mob that is
attempting to do him harm how do we know
they're attempting to do him harm
because he falls down and one of them
shouts get his ass at which point a man
jumps on him with a skateboard
and tries to club him with the
skateboard at this point rittenhouse
shoots the guy who's trying to club him
with the skateboard and there's another
man who's approaching him with a pistol
now we don't know if this guy with the
pistol
is the one who originally fired the shot
in the air at the at the
incident a minute and a half earlier
okay and here is what
it looked like when he shot two other
people one of these guys died he was
running toward the police by the way to
turn himself in
right this is what he was doing okay so
you can see this guy
this guy hits him from behind here are
people chasing him
you can see he's pushed from behind and
he falls he falls down on the ground
he turns around and a guy tries to jump
on him with the skateboard there's
several people trying to jump on him he
shoots one of them and then another guy
has a gun and he shoots him in the arm
the guy who's shot in the arm does have
a pistol there are pictures of him half
his arm is gone because this is what
happens when you get hit close range by
a bullet
and then he's trying to surrender the
cops don't actually know what's going on
at this point so they drive past him
so people have been using this as why
didn't they arrest him because they
don't know what's going on yet he's
with his hands up that's why they don't
arrest him like why didn't they shoot
him they shot jacob blake because he
wasn't going for a knife against the
cops that would be the reason guys
trevor noah idiot was like oh well jacob
blake got shot why didn't they shoot
this guy because he literally was not
pointing a gun at them that would be the
reason
by the way lots of criminals don't get
shot by the
hey cops people pointed out that the
shooter in charles in in charleston the
the
horrible racist shooting of the
terrorist attack on the black church in
charleston that shooter was captured
alive by the cops
right because he didn't try to shoot the
cops the the washington dc snipers were
also captured alive by the cops
they were black because they weren't
trying to shoot the cops okay in any
case
he ends up being arrested and charged
with first-degree murder based on this
tape it's gonna be very difficult to
sustain a first-degree murder conviction
like extremely difficult he there's no
evidence according to the senator from
connecticut calls him deranged white
supremacist no evidence
of that also there is no evidence that
he was out there to shoot people
right he's literally running away from
people in both of these tapes the only
way you get a first degree murder
conviction is if he was
threatening somebody with the gun before
somebody tried to jump him or something
okay we don't have evidence of that by
the way who are the people who are
killed
the who are the people who are shot
we'll get to their backgrounds in just
one second because it does add some it
does add some context to what exactly
happened we'll get some more of this in
just one second first
it's kind of chaotic out there right now
you may have noticed and a lot of people
are asking in the middle of a pandemic
with rye is burning in our major cities
and things sucking this much
can i even get life insurance the answer
is yes and if you're a responsible human
being you should get life insurance
it's still easy to shop for life
insurance right now if you have loved
ones depending on your income you
probably should
right now you could save 1500 bucks or
more a year by using policy genius to
compare life insurance policies
when you're shopping for a policy that
could last for a decade or more the
savings really start to add up
so what is policy genius well it's an
insurance marketplace built in backed by
a team of industry experts
here's how it works step one go to
policy genius and in minutes they will
work out how much coverage you need
and compare quotes from top insurers and
find your best price two you apply three
policy genius does the rest so really
really easy you can save yourself tons
of money on life insurance and if you're
a responsible human being you should
the policy genius service really allows
you to take it easy while they do all
the hard work
for you it's giving them a fi they have
a five-star rating across over 1600
reviews on trustpilot and google as well
so if you need life insurance be a
responsible human being take care of
your family head on over to
policygenius.com right now to get
started you could say 1500
or more a year by comparing quotes on
their marketplace policy genius when it
comes to insurance it's nice to get it
right
okay so who are the people who are
actually shot and you know doing the
reporting that the mainstream media will
not do
the first guy who was shot the one who
died and there's a daily caller reporter
on scene who took off his shirt tried to
turn and cut the guy's head the guy died
anyway
the media by the way really downplayed
the fact that there was a right-wing
reporter trying to help
a a protester slash rider looter
who was threatening the the teen shooter
his name was joseph rosenbaum who's 36
video allegedly showed him chasing the
teen shooter and throwing something at
him
and then he kind of ducks behind a car
before the shooting actually happens he
was a registered sex offender for a sex
crime involving a minor you can also see
him on tape a little bit earlier in the
night
threatening people and uh so it seems
like um
maybe the aggressor here in the original
iteration
might not have been kyle rittenhouse
here is the tape of this guy
this is what minutes before the actual
[Music]
shooting
okay so you can see him there he's in
the red shirt and he is saying the
n-word
he is saying the n word at that point uh
it ends with an a in his in his
iteration okay and
this is the person who ended up being
shot apparently uh so that is that is
one person
the second person who was shot is a
person named anthony huber shot and
killed
he was filmed chasing down the teen and
hitting him when he was on the ground
with the skateboard
he has a criminal history including
charges of battery and repeat domestic
abuse and the third person who was shot
and survived
is a person named gage grosskroots who
is 26 a member of the people's
revolution movement
he was filmed chasing after the teen
with a pistol and was shot at close
range in the upper arm
and he has a criminal record as well
including being intoxicated and armed
with a gun so there are all your facts
all of your facts most of which you will
not receive from the mainstream media
except for that one
late-breaking but good thorough report
from the new york times
so the story you've been told is that
this kid was a deranged white
supremacist militia member who went out
looking for blood
there is little to no evidence that that
is the case it's going to be very
difficult to sustain a first degree
murder charge against
this person now meanwhile the
the danger levels were rising in kenosha
wisconsin
there's tape of one of the people who is
one of the writers and looters
encouraging the blm crowd
to head on off to people's homes and
harass them at their homes and
businesses which is always a great look
let's go over where the police are where
the man is you know that's the that's
the line here so we're going to go over
into
peaceful civilian areas and uh and
create chaos so that that's always
a great look so how did the media cover
all of this so the media have been
downplaying writing and looting they've
been saying that it's a myth
it's it's something in your imagination
for a long time did the media
change their minds when it turns out
that it is not only not a myth americans
are worried about it of course not
this is an actual chiron that appeared
on cnn last night it was so insane
i thought it had to be photoshopped when
i first saw it last night so there's a
segment cnn aired
they had a reporter on the ground this
is not the reporters faulting right the
chiron
and in this segment you can see
literally things burning behind the
reporter
so here is the reporter in kenosha
wisconsin you're gonna hear him talk
the chiron underneath literally things
are burning in the background you can
sit you can see
cars businesses burning in the
background the chiron from cnn
your most trusted name in news your
media who are actively rooting for
rioting and looting and justifying
writing and looting and excusing it and
proclaiming that anyone who opposes
rioting and looting is opposed to black
lives
and all this bull crap okay here is
cnn's kyron i'm gonna read it to you
okay you ready
fiery but mostly peaceful protests after
police shooting
fiery but mostly peaceful protest so
here's what we've got from the media
he had a knife but otherwise unarmed and
fiery but mostly peaceful protests
after police shooting they think you're
a they think you're an actual
you're looking at a tape of crap burning
in the background and the chiron i don't
know
who wrote like who the hell did the did
the rioters write the the chiron
apparently fiery but mostly peaceful
protests
yes in the titanic voyage as my friend
bridge of fedex he says the titanic
voyage was watery but mostly
mostly safe fiery but mostly peaceful
protests
after police shooting they're justifying
the writing they're justifying the
looting they want it they like it
there's no other way to justify that
chiron
that's that's insane that's insane and
then of course
you get the the the members of the cnn
crew trying to blame trump for the
unrest
is a single one of these areas governed
by
by republicans the answer is no they've
been governed by democrats for decades
here's anderson cooper trying to blame
trump for the unrest trump
who has nothing to do with this okay
here's anderson cooper
the vice president is saying and quote
we will have law and order on the
streets of america
uh future tents we will have it
but this is the trumps america i mean he
has been now in power
it is if the vice president and the
president are talking as if
they are just observers to what is going
on as if they are the inc
they are running to unseat the sitting
president vice president they are the
this is the administration this is their
vision for
america their vision for america is the
writing and the looting
when trump sent in federal forces to try
and stop this stuff
in chicago and in portland anderson
cooper and the rest of the cnn jackasses
were sitting around talking about how he
was a fascist
jake tapper who's normally much better
than this but jake tapper yesterday was
like look at these
rnc people they're dehumanizing the
rioters and the looters
you damn right okay like it is not
humane or human behavior it is inhuman
behavior
to participate in rioting and looting
that is not behavior that should be
humanized
it is not good behavior okay you should
be treated with disdain if you are
rioting and if you are looting
and no i'm not talking about protesters
here the media do this fun little trick
where if you specifically say
that you think that rioting and looting
is inhumane behavior and should not be
humanized
that if you say that then you are
somehow dehumanizing protesters they're
not the same group and if you keep
treating them as the same group
then you are actually doing a disservice
to the protesters of course but here is
jake tapper saying it's very bad that
republicans keep using this you know
inflammatory language about people who
are burning crap and trying to kill
people
jake is better than this and i'm shocked
at him frankly we've known that this was
going to break throughout the night and
i wondered
if that was going to temper at all some
of the language we have heard
from republican officials talking about
the mob talking about these protesters
in very dehumanizing ways this
individual if he is guilty he is
responsible for his crimes not any of
the individuals
he supports including president trump
but the idea
that a supporter of president trump is
accused of
killing protesters last night
okay the what okay first of all you may
want to actually include the facts of
the case there jake it turns out that by
video the guy is probably defending
himself
it's gonna be very difficult to sustain
a first-degree murder charge in that
particular case
and then to blame that on trump and then
to suggest how dare people use
dehumanizing language about a mob of
people who are attempting to burn
businesses and loot things
and be the world's worst humans if this
is the i don't know how to read the
media treatment of this other than they
are rooting for the writers and looters
i don't know how to read that
i'd love to read it another way i mean
there's an abc news reporter last night
who's like well
trump you know he keeps doing this thing
where he leans into law and order why is
he leaning into law and order
maybe he's leaning into law order
because the cities are damned on fire
like what in the actual hell is wrong
with these people
this is abc news last night
silence from the president on the
shooting of jacob blake he was briefed
on it days ago but so far
has not made any public comments instead
what you're seeing from the president
is him leaning into his law and order
message saying that the governor of
wisconsin should call in
the national guard to help with the
racial unrest and the violence
in his state and that does serve as a
sharp contrast
to what his rival joe biden is saying it
draws a sharp contrast because biden
is so sympathetic and empathetic by the
way we're gonna get to joe biden in just
a second who continues to throw fuel on
the fire i understand that yesterday he
made a statement
where he in very measured terms says
that it's unnecessary to engage in
rioting and looting and then proceeded
to justify basically every element of
the writing and looting he just said
don't be so pissed off vote for me right
this is the blackmail game that the
democrats
are playing barack obama played it last
week the protesters are the best among
us riots and looters don't exist
and by the way the only way to heal this
the system works if you just vote for us
you just vote for us and then you don't
have to write and loot
because all your problems will be solved
okay
american voters should not acquiesce to
this this game of extortion
where democratic politicians essentially
pat on the head
rioters and looters for months on end in
places like portland and seattle and
chicago and new york and washington dc
and los angeles
and then they say well yes but if you
elect us don't worry the system is still
working
it's despicable we're gonna get to more
of this in just one second first
you know right now you might be feeling
a little bit unsafe a little unsafe that
would not be a surprise but
here's the thing you really have to know
how to handle your weapon you have to
know how to handle a gun if you're a
responsible gun owner because you have
to know
what the law is you do i mean there are
situations where
you're walking with your kids and
somebody comes up to you and maybe
they're carrying a gun maybe they're not
and they seem to be threatening you
well you better know your rights and you
better know how to use the gun because
there are two things that could go wrong
there one
something bad could happen to you too
you could misproperly improperly
utilize the gun you could find yourself
in serious legal trouble
this is why you need a 100 free copy of
the complete concealed carry and family
defense guide from the us concealed
carry association you need a gun to
protect yourself and your family and you
know how to you need to know
how to use it and when to use it that
free copy of the
complete concealed carry and family
defense guide from the uscca it's 164
pages it comes with a bonus audio
version so you can listen
whenever you want it's important to own
a firearm it's important to know how and
when to use it responsibly if the need
arises just text protect to 87222 to get
that free guide
you'll get instant access and a chance
to win a thousand bucks so you can buy a
gun to protect your family
text protect to 87 222 right now and
join my friends at the uscca they're
doing excellent work text protect
to 87 222 right now and we're going to
get more into
the insane push by the media to ratchet
up racial tension
the inability of joe biden to ratchet
down or the unwillingness of joe biden
to ratchet down such tension will get
into the nba
essentially posturing and ending its
season in order to accomplish some
unspecified gold they've yet today
we'll get to that in a second first in
case you haven't tuned in this week the
rnc
has had some really good stuff in in
terms of production value in terms of
actual content
it completely outpaced the dnc i mean
the rnc is significantly better than the
dnc we're going to get some more of that
in a little while daily wire is matching
this enthusiasm with an even better
lineup of all access live to watch the
rnc with you over at dailywire.com
tonight
8 15 p.m eastern 5 15 pm pacific the
ex-girl michael moles will be live
streaming the final night of the rnc
speakers including president trump
who will be watching with you are all
access members taking your questions and
comments live as well only all access
members get to join
these all access live sessions where one
of us hosts hops on every night to chat
with you both in live stream and in the
comments
all access membership also features not
one but two leftist tiers tumblers with
your membership as well as early
sometimes exclusive access to new daily
wire products so head on over to
dailywire.com
shapiro right now to get 20 off all
access with coupon code access that's
dailywire.com with coupon code access to
get 20
off your membership you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so the narrative that has been
promulgated of course the underlying
narrative of america is systemically
racist every iteration
of a black person being shot is just
another element it's another brick in
the wall
for the case against america as an
institution and as a system
right this by the way is the open agenda
of people like abram kennedy who
suggests that literally everything that
goes wrong in america is due to
america's systemic racism
and therefore america's institutions
must be pulled down from the top and
from the root must be just completely
exploded
and if you don't do that you're not
anti-racist which means you're a racist
because they're only two categories
racist and anti-racist
and abram candy's garbage view of the
world
well this leads to some pretty
predictable effect people immediately
jump
on any incident without any evidence to
immediately suggest that america is
systemically racist and then they go and
they riot and they loot
okay so in minneapolis there was rioting
and looting again in minneapolis last
night there was looting in downtown
minneapolis people were just breaking
into stores in downtown
minneapolis why what happened in
minneapolis last night
well the answer is there was a homicide
suspect who shot himself
okay so what does that have to do with
the cops what's what what do the cops do
well the cops didn't do anything people
were looting the sacks off
fifth location until police dispersed
the crowd with tear gas
apparently people were throwing bottles
setting off commercial grade fireworks
there were reports of shots fired
hennepin county sheriff dave hutchinson
said we got cops all over the twin
cities coming out here to maintain order
because the citizens of minneapolis and
hennepin county deserve to feel safe
apparently they'd stop the light rail
service on the blue and green lines they
stopped trains and buses
to downtown minneapolis people gathered
around the scene
in the aftermath of the suicide and then
they just started lying and said that he
was shot by the police
they they they looted the target which
is a great way of protesting racial
injustice is by stealing
that's definitely the best way to do
this
governor tim walls of course doing an
amazing job he said minneapolis it's
time to heal
we must rebuild and recover dangerous
unlawful behavior will not be tolerated
the state patrol is headed to
minneapolis to help restore order i
remain in close contact with the city
and every state resource stands ready to
help bring peace
oh good you know months later well done
everybody so what exactly happened
in this case there's a suspect who was
followed by police in connection to a
deadly shooting that happened just hours
before
at a parking ramp downtown the guy shot
himself he killed himself
people showed up they started lying and
suggesting that
this person who shot himself was
murdered by the police and then riots
broke out and looting
well done everybody because you know
what honestly what's the for the media
what's the difference they won't cover
the details of these shootings anyway
and when they do it's always this
post-hoc rationalization whereby
whatever the details of the case the
narrative has to be sustained by the way
how bad do minneapolis business owners
have it right now how badly do
minneapolis business owners have it
right now there's a story from the
minneapolis star tribune
in which they point out that business
owners have been explicitly barred by
the law
from taking measures to protect their
own businesses
according to jeffrey mytrot at the star
tribune quote minneapolis businesses
fight ban on exterior shutters wind uh
shutters owners wanting to protect their
their windows after riots face
obstacle okay so in other words looters
crash through windows and people started
putting up exterior shutters on the
outside of the building
but the city of minneapolis has barred
security shutters on business exteriors
since 2004.
why because they said that they the
external shutters cause visual blight
and they create the impression that an
area is unsafe and troublesome
well you wouldn't want to create that
impression i mean let the business owner
suffer but you don't want to create the
impression that things are going badly
in minneapolis by allowing people to put
up shutters
instead why don't you create the
impression that things are going badly
in minneapolis by allowing rioters and
looters to shatter all the windows
good call everybody just well done all
the way around well shockingly democrats
were
silenced about this completely at the
dnc last week they were completely
silent about it like not a word
not a word and for months they've been
putting out these extraordinarily tepid
statements well
you know we don't really like the
violence but but
america is a systemically racist place
and you have to understand what these
people are going through et cetera et
cetera et cetera
well now it turns out that the polling
sucks for democrats on this it turns out
that americans aren't real fond of
watching writers and looters in the
streets
including by the way many black
americans who live in the areas that are
being rioted against and looted in
there is a public opinion poll that was
done before the jacob blake shooting and
events in kenosha
and what it showed is a dramatic drop a
dramatic decline
in the approval of black lives matter
protests
in early june from june to from from
june 14th to 18th
the there are 61 of americans said they
approved of blm 36
disapprove by the beginning
of august those numbers were back to
4848.
okay in the aftermath of what's
happening in kenosha in minneapolis i
can guarantee you this is going to drop
into negative territory which is where
it should be since the blm movement has
accomplished zero things i'm still
waiting what have they accomplished
the the one thing that anybody tried to
accomplish was senator tim scott pushing
a police reform bill which was
immediately filibustered by the
democrats what's the thing they've
accomplished
other than ratcheting up racial tensions
across the country and making excuses
for rioters and looters and fiery things
happening to burst out at protests all
over the country
black or hispanic approval of blm
remains high
but white approval has fallen and become
net negative which is not particularly
shocking the the levels of black and
hispanic approval have remained pretty
steady
throughout but what did this drive well
it means that joe biden and the
democrats are starting to feel the
pressure
they're starting to feel the pressure in
places like wisconsin according to the
new york times
wisconsin voters are looking at what's
happening and they're saying uh maybe i
need to vote for trump so i'm not going
to get blackmailed into supporting the
very people who are trying to burn down
my business
according to the new york times the
politically calculated warnings of
president trump and the republican party
about chaos enveloping america should
democrats win in november are
reverberating among some people in
kenosha first of all i gotta love the
new york times coverage it's politically
calculated
it's not that it's an actual warning
it's politic it's always politically
calculated
republicans pounce republicans seize you
know how they would not be able to
pounce overseas
if democratic governors and mayors would
shut this stuff down
okay but apparently there are fears in
the democratic party that rural areas
of swing states like pennsylvania and
michigan and wisconsin
aren't going to like all that much the
democratic pensions for making excuses
for people who burn cities
and so joe biden had to release a
statement yesterday so finally he
releases an actual
spoken statement he's released some
written statements before
extraordinarily tempted
he released a spoken statement the first
minute of which was dedicated to
suggesting that the police and the jacob
blake shooting were actual racists were
murdering black people without evidence
by the way
so it's so funny people i saw some more
conciliatory types on the right being
like well at least biden put out a
statement i'm so glad he finally
condemned the violence
okay if the first minute of what you're
saying is that america is so
systemically racist and terrible that
black people are being shot willy-nilly
by the cops and then you say you know
but violence is unnecessary comply with
the law these are two conflicting
messages
if you suggest that america is so
inherently dangerous that black people
are being systemically put under the
knife put under the boot
of the jack-booted racist in charge of
the police and the institutions of
america
then when you buy it back five seconds
later and you're like well yes but if
you elect me if you then then
everything's better and
the violence is unnecessary and it's not
it's not useful
well i've yet to see why if you're a
writer and a looter you would think that
considering that you've received nothing
but
downplaying of your violence and
downplaying of your looting and
warm coverage as protesters who are the
best of america from many of america's
chief political voices here is joe biden
putting out a statement that is
self-defeating
and will accomplish nothing but was
cheered by the media as well now he's
taking it seriously oh really or is this
just part of a tacit extortion scheme
whereby democrats basically suggest that
if you elect them they'll make the riots
go away
but if you don't elect them then you
know stuff happening in major cities
that's just the predictable result of an
evil evil america
what i saw on that video makes me sick
once again a black man
jacob blake has been shot by the police
in broad daylight
with the whole world watching you know
our hearts are with his family
especially his children
it's horrible what they saw watching
their father get shot can you pause it
for one second
okay that's the part that people are
going to watch first and foremost right
it makes you sick to your stomach what
you saw on that tape once again a black
man being shot in broad daylight
at no point here does he actually go
through the facts of the case at no
point does he point out that jacob blake
was resisting arrest had an open warrant
for two separate charges including a
felony and when he went to his car there
was a
knife on the floorboards at no point
does the factual pattern enter anywhere
into this calculation for joe biden
it's just another example of any time a
bad thing happens to a black person it's
because of
systemic american racism and then he
goes forward and he's like but you know
you probably shouldn't riot and burn
stuff because it's uncouth
it's uncouth yeah i'm sure that's a
message that's going to resonate
well well yes i'm sure that's going to
stop all the violence by the way you
know what stops violence on the streets
when you put
protective forces on the streets to stop
the violence when you put the cops out
there to stop the violence when you
suggest the police are systemically
racist
and then you say don't commit acts of
violence but the police are systemically
racist
and they're the only people who are
going to stop you from committing acts
of
rioting and looting and violence what do
you think is going to happen
you're literally saying the only people
who can stop the acts of violence are
the racists
that's what joe biden is saying right
here okay that's the tacit message but
don't worry if he's elected he'll heal
it all the police will magically become
great people again
here's joe biden then tepidly condemning
violence
it's horrible what they saw watching
their father get shot
like gianna floyd they're asking why
why daddy protesting brutality is a
right
and absolutely necessary but burning
down communities
is not protest it's needless violence
it's needless needless is the word he
uses right if we're needed then maybe
it's okay but it's needless it's
needless
it's not evil it's not morally bereft
it's not disgusting
to burn down businesses it's needless
and it's needless because eventually
you're going to elect me and i'm going
to heal all this stuff
job in there he's talking about gianna
floyd by the way that would be the um
what the wife of george floyd
i guess the daughter of george floyd
sorry about that so just the quick
correction there okay so
all of this is calculated to lead to
more violence because guess what
the democratic agenda has now become
extraordinarily clear which is we will
typically condemn violence from time to
time but we are not actually going to do
anything to stop the violence in any
real way
i mean believe it or not i'm not kidding
you
the virginia legislature which is now a
democratic legislature
the virginia legislature just passed a
bill
that would make it a non-make it a
misdemeanor a misdemeanor to assault a
police officer if the police officer was
not hurt
i'm not kidding this is in real time
what the virginia legislature is doing
the virginia senate according to
wsls passed a bill allowing assaulting a
police officer to be considered a
misdemeanor and removing a mandatory
jail sentence
this is madness it's madness you're
getting rid of penalties for assaulting
police officers
you're suggesting that america is racist
stem to stern and then you sit around
you're like oh well you know
and if there's there's looting and
violence that's unnecessary guys it's
unnecessary after all you can just elect
democrats
by the way democrats have been running
these cities for years and i'm still
seeing some looting and some violence
and pretty significant levels
of of police interactions with the local
population
okay so all this leads up to popular
culture and so this message has now
infused all aspects of our society
and you're not considered woke if you
won't mirror the narrative of the day
and the narrative of the day is america
is evil and systemically racist
and all bad and evil decisions by
individuals are attributable to that
evil american system
so all this carries forward to the nba
so the nba is already having some pretty
significant problems
right the nba didn't play for a while
because of the pandemic
and then they created this bubble which
is a pretty smart idea where they're
going to play all of our games in one
place
but in order for you to watch the games
you have to swallow whole all the social
justice
crap that they're pushing like america
is systemically racist and evil
and listen all these athletes have a
right to speak their americans just like
anybody else that doesn't mean they know
what the hell they're talking about or
that what they're saying is good for the
country
so the nba slathers its product in blm
messaging slathers it
i mean they've got black lives matter
huge emblazoned slogans still bill de
blasio fifth avenue style
on the sidelines of the games they
decide that all the players get to wear
whatever social justice messaging except
for free hong kong they want to put
on the back of their jerseys so you have
say his name throwing up an alley-oop to
equality
and there's been a thing inside the
bubble and americans are not
particularly interested the ratings drop
they drop because number one if there's
no crowd you're playing inside the
bubble it's not as exciting but number
two because a lot of people like me who
are sort of casual nba fans like
i enjoy basketball i'll watch it if it's
on but i'm not gonna like go out of my
way it's
not the center of my universe or
anything a lot of casual basketball fans
like nope not gonna do it
and in fact for other sports where i'm
much more passionate i also wouldn't do
it right when
mlb started doing start of the season
with the we're going to kneel
at the beginning and hold a black cloth
while morgan friedman reads a social
justice message poetry
i was like you know what i don't have to
watch baseball i'll find other things to
do i got kids i got a life
a lot of people felt that way about the
nba you end up killing your market
when you decide that you're going to
specifically alienate one aspect of the
market
and yes people have differing political
views in the united states and typically
when they watch sports they don't expect
to be hit
with political views there are plenty of
things on tv you can watch if you want
to be political you can watch this show
you can go watch pod save america if you
disagree
there's plenty of stuff that you can
watch but mostly when people tune into
sports
they're not particularly interested in
the sporting product itself
being slathered in this sort of stuff i
mean this is perfectly obvious and it's
been obvious for a very long time again
doesn't mean athletes can't speak out
they can
but that also doesn't mean athletes know
what they're talking about or that it is
smart business
and to slather your product and this
sort of stuff okay so the nba did all
this they played in the bubble
they created this coveted bubble where
where presumably everybody did not have
coven
which was again a smart move by adam
silver then they slathered their product
in a bunch of sjw crap
and people were like you know what not
so into it and the ratings dropped
something like 50
well now lebron james and the lakers and
the clippers and the milwaukee bucks
basically have decided that they're
going to suspend the season completely
so according to cbs sports the lakers
and the clippers pushed to end the
season after the jacob blake shooting
the wnba suspended all of its games
yesterday the mlb suspended a few of its
games yesterday
several of the leaders of the lakers
roster along with some players from
other teams stayed up into the early
morning hours to hash out their issues
inside the bubble
as a result there's optimism growing
that players want to continue the
playoffs supposedly but
during a meeting wednesday evening the
lakers and clippers were among the
minority of teams pushing to end the
season entirely
lebron james said in the meeting he
wants the team owners to be more
involved and take action
so the milwaukee bucks walked out of
their game five against the orlando
magic and then the orlando magic
walked out of the game and then the
rockets and thunder decided not to play
and then the lakers and trailblazers
decided not to play
okay well uh the background of this is a
series of statements over the past
72 hours after the jacob blake shooting
in which
famous members of the nba talked about
how america was evil and terrible and
black people live in abject fear of the
police
which statistically speaking is not even
close to true 81 percent of black
americans say they want the same number
of cops or more cops in their
communities
if you're talking about threats to black
lives in the united states the cops
don't rank in the top 20 on that list
okay they're not the threat to black
lives at least not if those
people are not committing crimes if
we're talking about innocent people or
not coming in crimes police are not
really on that list
the police are the people who stand
between law-abiding citizens and the
criminals they're putting their lives on
the lines every day doesn't mean they're
not racist cops there are some
because they're racist people in all
walks of life doesn't mean there aren't
bad cops there are some
the overwhelming overwhelming majority
of cops are people doing hard work to
protect law abiding citizens
of all races okay but the narrative went
out and the narrative was that jacob
blake was just another
just another incident of evil american
racism
so you get this lebron james just
because the man is very famous and very
wealthy and very good at basketball
doesn't mean he knows what in the hell
he is talking about
here is lebron james this is in the last
two days suggesting
that sometimes cops wake up in the
morning and they just want to shoot
black people he literally says this
he literally says this this is crazy
this is a crazy thing to say the cops
get up in the morning by the way
in major cities across america a
majority of the police force is minority
la where he lives is a majority minority
police force
hey here's lebron james suggesting the
cops get up in the morning just like i
feel like shooting a black guy today and
that's the real danger to black
americans
says the billionaire athlete who gets to
play a game dribbling a basketball for a
living
for entertainment i mean look all right
here's lebron james
you have no idea how that cop
that day left the house you don't know
if he walked on the good side of the bed
you don't know if you walk
work on the wrong side of the bed you
don't know if you had an argument at
home
with a significant other you know one of
his kids said something crazy to him and
he left the house steaming
or maybe he just left the house in and
today is going to be
the end for one of these black people
that's what it feels like i don't give a
crap what a quote unquote feels like to
lebron james i care about the actual
facts of the situation feelings don't
matter here the question is
are cops routinely leaving the house
being like i'm shooting a black guy
today that is such an
abject disgusting lie it's such a
disgusting lie there's no evidence to
back that
the implication that police officers are
waking up in the morning like i'm
shooting a black guy today is disgusting
it's disgusting and it turns all black
americans into victims of the police
which is a lie
it suggests that the removal of the
police is the solution which is an even
bigger lie and it's just that black
people largely don't have agency in
their own lives in the racist america
that is which is
the biggest lie of all black americans
are the richest black people ethnically
speaking on planet earth
black people who live in the united
states black people can be successful in
the united states
they are successful in the united states
the vast majority of black people are
not living in abject poverty
the vast majority of black people make
good decisions and get ahead in america
lebron james is one of those people who
has made those decisions in his personal
life
and yet the idea is that he's living
under the thumb of the white man in the
united states seriously
okay so doc rivers said the same thing
here's the coach of the los angeles
clippers his father was a cop by the way
doc rivers and he talks extensively he's
talked extensively in the past about his
father
and how his father talked about respect
for the police and his father said that
certain cops were bad and certain cops
were good and all of this but here's doc
rivers suggesting we're the ones getting
shot we're the ones getting killed the
country doesn't love us
really jack rivers you're
underperforming your contract pretty
dramatically here and you're being paid
about 5 million bucks a year
and it seems like you have a pretty good
life and it seems like the vast majority
of people in the united states
if they do not commit crimes don't come
into conflict with the police generally
here is here is doc rivers suggesting
that black people are the ones getting
shot and getting killed
for no reason because the country
doesn't love black americans
uh i'm going to need like an iota of
evidence that the country quote unquote
doesn't love black americans
here's zach rivers yes this was two days
ago
all you hear is donald trump and all of
them talking about fear
we're the ones getting killed we're the
ones getting shot
uh we're the ones that we're denied to
live in
certain communities we've been hung
we've been shot all you do is keep
hearing a fear
it's amazing why we keep loving
this country and this country does not
love us back
what absolute nonsense we keep loving
the country and the country doesn't love
us back
what evident we've had a black president
in my not in
in my lifetime in the last few years
until the last five minutes barack obama
was overwhelmingly elected twice the
most popular figures in america today
are largely largely there are many black
americans talking about oprah winfrey
michelle obama we're talking about
barack obama lebron james these are all
extremely
beloved people in american public life
where is he getting this
where is he getting this okay this is
not to suggest again
that there is no racism of course
there's racism in america but as nikki
haley correctly said
just because there is racism in america
does not mean that america is racist
there's anti-semitism in america that
does not mean that america is
anti-semitic
i've been the victim of anti-semitism in
america it does not mean that america
broadly speaking is anti-semitic and
that i'm a victim of an anti-semitic
system
okay so anyway the the basketball
players decide to walk out which by the
way is a tactic that makes no sense at
all
literally no sense so people are
comparing this to muhammad ali
giving up boxing because he didn't want
to go into the army
so i have my quibbles with the fact that
the nation of islam was using muhammad
ali as a prop at the time
and the nation of islam was run by some
pretty awful people
you know people who by the way murdered
malcolm x and all likely but in any case
putting aside the actual politics of
what muhammad
ali did at least muhammad ali was
quote-unquote boycotting the right
people
he said i don't want to go in the army
because i don't want to fight the viet
cong okay so he was taking an action
that was directly correlated with the
results he was seeking
i have a question what exactly did the
nba players
who are they boycotting well they're
boycotting the audience and the audience
is already largely signed off so there's
that
they're boycotting the owners who pay
their salaries which makes no sense
because the owners have by the way
largely signed on to every demand they
have ever made in terms of messaging on
social
justice and giving donations to various
leftist organizations and all the rest
they're boycotting their own job which
doesn't make a lot of sense i'm hearing
a lot today about how lebron james is
making a sacrifice
now lebron james is quote-unquote using
his voice it's just prerogative
but let's be real about this the
sacrifice that lebron james is making
is really the sacrifice of other players
careers because lebron james will be a
first
ballot hall of famer he's either the
first or the second best basketball
player who has ever lived
he is going to make more money in the
long run for the social justice activism
that he is pursuing right now as we saw
from colin kaepernick
the people who are actually damaged
inside the nba it's not lebron james
lebron james ain't taking the hit here
the person who's actually taking the hit
here is the seventh man for the
for the milwaukee bucks right so the guy
who's playing for the orlando magic way
down there on the bench who's playing on
a one-year contract
and needs to prove himself before his
knees give out two years from now and he
can't make money anymore right that's
the one who's paying the price lebron
ain't paying that price for this
lebron is getting celebrated for this so
that doesn't mean that what he's doing
is quote unquote
the wrong thing morally speaking he has
a right to do whatever he wants to do
it's america i think it's the wrong
thing because i think that he's
he's propagating a very bad and nasty
message about the country
and about police officers but the idea
that he's undergoing some sort of
massive sacrifice by walking out and by
forcing by the way
all the other players to walk out
because that's really what he does now
now the idea is that if you don't want
to walk out if you don't want to end the
nba season then you're some sort of
traitor to the social justice cause so
you have to sacrifice your career so
lebron james
can per so lebron james can push the
message that he finds
to be important that's effectively what
it means
the people who are going to pay by the
way are the people in the nba down the
line
who lose viewers because a lot of casual
nba viewers are not coming back they're
not
the lakers issued a statement their
statement was quote we stand with our
players and the players of the nba and
their demand for justice and the end of
racial violence wow
you you mean you you don't want racial
violence congratulations like
you mean just like every other sentient
human being in the united states you
don't want racial violence
by the way have they have they called
for a single policy the only thing that
i've heard from lebron james is he wants
the officers arrested in jacob blake's
case
and he wants the officers arrested
brianna taylor's case well you know it's
a way
that um justice doesn't work in the
united states lebron james demands
someone arrested and they're arrested
or oprah winfrey puts up billboards and
therefore officers get arrested and if
that's the way justice works in america
that ain't justice that's mob justice
and it's disgusting
you don't arrest people based on people
screaming that they should be arrested
that's by the way what lebron james has
been saying okay these many of these
public figures have been saying
we need these officers arrested right
when derek shavin got charged with third
degree murder and then keith ellison
elevated its second degree murder the
charge against chavin which by the way
is going to be very difficult to sustain
in court by the autopsy reports
and the reasonable doubt standard people
cheered they're like oh look
look at keith ellison he's increasing
the charge that's so great that's so
great
legal experts note you it's going to be
extraordinarily difficult
to convict derek chavin of second degree
or it would have been a little bit
easier to go for third degree if you
actually gave a crap about the law but
you know
all you care about is the virtue
signaling so the lakers said 80
of nba players are black men okay by the
way if we're gonna go by the diverse
standard
that population is supposed to be
represented by percentage
of demographic then we should ask some
questions about affirmative action in
the nba for people who are not black
presumably
that's the diversity standard is it not
in the end like we cannot love them for
the joy and entertainment they bring to
the world yet sit in silence and fail to
use our platforms and resources to
amplify their voices when they demand
the justice and equality that america
has promised us all but denied black
people for
too long in 2020 alone we've been made
to bear witness to the killings of
numerous unarmed black men
and women at the hands of police as well
as private vigilantes brianna taylor
george floyd ahmed arbury and now jacob
blake these cases are not all the same
the ahmedabary case is legit murder case
the briana taylor case is a case
where the police had to legit no knock
warrant they used the no knock warrant
they were shot at and they returned fire
it's a tragic situation it is not a
criminal one the george floyd case
is gonna be very difficult to prosecute
considering the man had enough fentanyl
in his system to kill a horse
and the fact that he was saying he
couldn't breathe before he was on the
ground you might be able to get
that officer for assault it's gonna be
very difficult to convict him of murder
on just a basic causation standard and
jacob blake looks like a justified
shooting he disobeyed every police
officer
he he wrestled away from them he
apparently was tased and walked away and
then he bent into a car and they found a
knife on the floorboards
okay but according to the lakers we must
continue to say their names but now
is also the time for us to say enough
okay well i'll tell you what's going to
happen a lot of people are going to say
enough to the nba a lot of people are
going to say you know what
you you're entitled to your politics and
we're entitled not to watch
this of course led to the the
pandering of barack obama so barack
obama tweeted out quote i commend the
players on the bucks for standing up for
what they believe in
coaches like doc rivers and the nba and
wnba for setting an example it's going
to take all our institutions to stand up
for our values
what change has been effectuated here
none what policy has been changed zero
what exactly has happened here nothing
all that matters is the narrative
because the narrative is a political
weapon for particular
points of view in the united states not
a single thing has been accomplished
other than the increasing
nastiness of our political discourse and
polarization around race
joe biden also put out a statement
commending the nba players
so joe biden's statement was
similarly milktoa said this moment
demands moral leadership
and these players answered by standing
up speaking out using their platform for
good
now is not the time for silence how
about now is the time to discuss you
know facts and solutions could we do
that
or are we just supposed to scream at the
wind and then when somebody else screams
at the wind and walks away from their
job in the middle of a pandemic i'm
by the way i'm i'm glad for the nba
players that they have the ability to
walk away from their jobs in the
in the middle of a pandemic where people
are literally not allowed to work
that's that's exciting for them i'm glad
and again they've every right to
made their voices heard and we have
every right to say that their voices are
making
very little difference in actually
obtaining solutions and a lot of
difference
in terms of propagating narratives that
are simply untrue about the united
states on a broad level
so okay fine so guess a lot of people
just won't watch the nba
that's that's the way it's going to go
because everything has to be politicized
everything again
no one's saying that these basketball
players can't speak out no one's saying
shut up and dribble they're free to
speak out
if they decide not to dribble we don't
have to watch and if they say stuff we
don't like we also don't have to watch
and that's america too especially if
you're pervading the lie
that america is a deeply evil and
systemically racist place and that every
police incident
is in is a symptomatic of a deeper
american evil that must be rooted out at
the core
uh to which i think a lot of people are
going to say well it seems like you're
doing pretty well in this evil terrible
america lebron james you're worth a
billion dollars
i'm glad that you have the temerity to
speak up against systemic american
racism in an awful evil unfree system in
which you're worth a billion dollars but
you don't have the temerity to stand up
to the evil chinese government that is
that is subjecting people to brutality
violence cruelty and tyranny
in hong kong and domestically a lot
takes a lot of courage takes a lot of
courage
all righty well we'll be back here later
today with two additional hours of
content we didn't even get to the rnc
today suffice it to say it was pretty
good it was pretty well run
the the the real rnc is what's happening
in these major american cities where
democrats refuse
to actually stop the violence and
propagate american values instead of
undermining them
we'll get to more of this later today
with two additional hours of content
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowski our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina hair and makeup is
by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because
the american republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moon has turned to blood but on
the andrew clavin show that's where the
fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton